[DRAMATIC CHAIR SPIN]
I know what you're thinking...
[LIGHTING! SINGING! OPERA!]
Who the hell is that handsome...
mmm...
young baby? *laughs*
*very attractive*
[Felix scratches beard angrily]
Where did my face go?!
WHAT'S THE POINT?!
GOD! I'm so angry...
[Puts on Glasses like a boss...]
Today
we're going to play a Video Game
about not moving.
Is it possible?
[Felix takes a quick look back]
I DON'T KNOW!
That's why I'm sitting down.
alright?
This is technically the first video I recorded
with the new Oculus
*breathes*
It's pretty cool! I like how it feels...
[that's what she said...]
they have the headphones built in.
Annnd...
Now we're gonna play
DON'T
LET
GO.
Hopefully you guys can see it.
So i play "The Office."
Check out the video!!!!
Now we're going to play "Desert"
*WHITE!*
Do not play if you have fear...
ok...
Oh my god
[wind whistling]
Oh my god...
*GASPS*
I'M IN THE DESERT!
[okay, calm your tits Felix]
THIS IS SO COOL!
What happens in the desert?
Alright
So these are the controls?
Wait I gotta-
Got the lens here...
it's all smudgy from my face.
Spacebar for Explanation...
Key...
[Felix goes crazy & hits two invisible drums]
Can't fucking see!
It is really cool now 'cause the Oculus-
you move with your body.
This wasn't a thing before...
[thinks of a quick joke]
So if I wanted to suck someone's dick-
[BEEP]
Now let's see if I can find both controller
OHH LOOK I'M SQUATTING!!
Heee-HEHAHAHAHA!
[insert fanfiction clip here]
This is SO WEIRD!
THIS IS SO FUCKING WEIRD!
HEEEY
YEAAH
EH EH!
Okay
Alright
Enough fucking around
Let's go
I DID IT!
Alright, that's a scorpion...
Oh god that's a bug...
We're watching Wikipedia Scorpions...
[Felix get's anxious...]
Where's the scorpion??
[Tries to look for his Scorpion]
WHERE THE FUCK YOU
YOU SON OF A BITCH!
Oh god...
It really feels like my hands
AWWWWH
You fucking-
EHHHHH
You disg- [gathers saliva]
[Felix probably spit on his mic...]
PPAA!
OHHHHHHHHHHHHH
WHAT!
THAT IS SO WEIRD!
NOPE!
DON'T TOUCH MY THUMB
Oh god it's gonna sting me...
Ohh...
please...
[Felix thinks this is the end of his life]
eh...
[Scorpion thinks about it...]
[Scorpion spared his life]
AHHHHHHHHHHHH
[Scorpion maybe changed his mind?]
NOOOOOOOOOO
*sobs*
What are yo-
[Felix spits on his mic again]
I'M SO TEMPTED TO
LET GOOOOOOOO
[Eagle Sounds]
FUCK!
AHHHHH!
SPONSOR EAGLE
THANK YOU!!!
*kiss*
I LOVE YOU!!!
WOOOOOOOOOOOOO
Still alive...
Thank you Sponsor Eagle...
You're my best friend
BE FREE
[Felix has now felt a strong relationship with Sponsor Eagle]
*sad sigh*
[Felix misses Sponsor Eagle...]
HUE!
JAVLA!
Oh my god.
[Felix checks if the Scorpion]
Is that alive?
Better not be
SPONSER-
HUE! JAVLA! FUCKIN' Sponsor Eagle...
I mean I love you...
Thank you
Have a snack.
[Felix gets lost in his eyes for a few seconds...]
Yeah that's right
Yeah
Eat that son of a bitch
You're my favourite Eagle, man...
I would pet you...
But ahh...
y'know I can't let go.
That's the point of a game
Sponsor Eagle...
[Sponsor Eagle does not give a fuck.]
Who you looking for?
Oh my god
Is there someone behind me?
No.
Is there a Cowboy?
I hate Cowboys
They're scaring me...
That's my biggest Phobia
Are you gonna eat that?
Or can I have a slice?
C'mon
[Felix hits the beak of the Eagle]
OW!
Jesus...
The fuck was that?
[Sponsor Eagle flies off]
Okay well I guess I'll see you later
[Looks at crotch, Felix is in the mood...]
OHHHHHHHHHHH
EHHHHHHHHHHH
Fuck
I gotta adjust my headset
But
I can't let go... :(
OHHHHHHHHHHHH
EHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHH
[GLASS SHATTERS, EARS BLEED]
[Felix's version of Opera]
EHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHH!!!
IT'S EAR-FUCKING ME!!!
O_O
Hey buddy
How you doin' there buddy?
This is so fucked up!
EHHHH
I wanna let go so bad...
[Poor Felix]
Can I kiss-
OHH!
no... :(
OHHH
I'M SORRY
[Felix repeatedly says 'sorry']
OH IT GOES BACK IN THE SCREEN
[Felix wants to be friends with the snake now...]
That's so cool
THAT IS
SO
COOL
[Felix is satisfied...]
Thank you Wikipedia
for teaching me again
Oh god there's a well there...
I just realised there's a well
and something's gonna come out of the well...
[Felix scratches ear with his shoulder...]
GOD
DAMN IT!
WHAT!
[Felix is shocked...]
Now you no-
Now you've gotten too far man...
WHAT THE SHIT IS THAT?
[A UFO...]
I mean I know- Oh no no no no...
Don't beam me up man...
I don't want to be
disinfect-
dissing-
'D'
dissected
whatever...
[Felix gave up looking for the right word...]
What is it doing?
Is it-
Something's gonna come down or...
[Felix attempts to swallow his tongue R.I.P]
TAKE ME HOME MOM!
Take me to home where I belong...
What is this?...
Wha-
[Felix is confused...]
Why a UFO?
Okay
Well I-
ain't afraid of
fucking
fucking fairies...
This is just-
nice
Hey fairies
How you doing?
Can I eat you?
I'm gonna eat you!
I'm gonna fucking eat you mate
[Felix attempts to try and swallow his tongue again]
What are they-
Tase me bro
C'mon
TASE ME BRO!
C'MON TASE ME THEN!
IS THIS ALL YOU'VE GOT?!
[Felix is speaking to God]
I AM NOT ENTERTAINED!
I would thumbs-
this down if I could use my hands...
Be Gone
BITCH!
[Felix is now disappointed...]
[He watches the UFO sadly fly off...]
Thanks for nothing!
Saw a UFO today
Oh yeah! What happened?
Oh a bunch of sparkles flew up...
Who gives a shit?
*ground shakes*
Oh god
An earthquake!
OH GOD!
*THUMP!*
WOOOAH!!!
OH!
GOD!
DAMN IT!
WHAT THE
FUCK?!
[EVERYONE COVER YOUR FUCKING EARS!!!]
OH GOD!!
*Monster noise...*
[Alright cover your ears in 3...]
3...
2...
1...
X _ X
[not done...]
R.I.P "TheBroArmy"
*chuckles*
*high-pitched gasp*
OHHHHHHHHHHHHH
I'M THE BEST!
GOD DAMN!
PLAYA!
ON THE PLANET!
I did not let go!
Well...
That was so cool
God damn that was cool...
You can check out the video where I play
the first one.
I think the Oculus works the best
when you are static
Like when you just sitting down
and you not moving
'Cause if you move in a game
annnd
you're not moving in real life,
that is what really creates motion Sickness
I get motion Sick really easily
uhh...
but this works fine.
This works excellent!
I wanna see more stuff like this!
I think that would be really cool
Uhh... let me know!
What's your opinion?
about the Oculus.
What do you think?
Is it a gimmick?
Is it gonna catch on?
I don't know!
I'm excited for the future!
This has been Pewdiepie
playing "Don't Let Go!"
Thank you so much for watching!
*kisses fist*
And as always...
STAY AWESOME BROS!
*brofist*
OH GOD!   *grunts*
Ah GWAD
*fells
OH
SHIT *grunts*
Shit
Huh
Where the baby go???
Where did baby go?  Where did baby go?
Where the baby go!!??
WHERE THE BABY GO!!!
Where did baby go?
OMG ITS BOUNCING
OHMYGAWD I'm bouncing!
FUCKING HIPSTER BABY
FUCKING HIPSTER BABY!
AHHH
OH
WHAT THE-
*laughs*
WHAT THE FUCK IS THIS!!!!!
WHAT THE FUCK IS THIS?!
GO fucking babies!!!